but fair use is the way these channels
are doing it
so that they can ultimately draft off
the
influence of celebrities athletes
movies trending headlines news
using footage in brief excerpts
commentary
combining it all together to make videos
that make a massive impact
if you feel like you're not getting
views then today's
episode is for you we are in a two-part
series
talking all about trend surfing and if
you did not listen to
episode number one make sure you go back
and listen to that one we break down
what trend surfing is we give you case
studies from
everyday creators just like you and
we tell you how to find the trends in
your niche so make sure you listen to
that
episode in today's episode we're going
to be sharing the new ways to get
discovered
what videos you should be creating the
formula for success
on trend surfing videos and what we
learned
from one of our favorite actors that's
right tom cruise
shout out to all the before 2000s babies
and what he teaches us on youtube my
name is heather torres and you're
listening to
the think media podcast the number one
podcast to help you grow your influence
on youtube
and then turn that influence into a high
impact and high profit
youtube channel and i'm so excited for
today's episode
not because we mentioned tom cruise but
because you're actually learning
about trend surfing this is one of our
favorite things to do here at think
media
we're going to give you more case
studies to that and dive deeper
into how you can use it for your youtube
channel and
before we get into the featured content
i want to remind you that our
upcoming free 5 day youtube challenge
is right around the corner you can sign
up today
at tube1kchallenge.com we're going to be
helping you get to your first
1000 subscribers and your first 1 000
on youtube will be sharing brand new
content to give you step by step
on how to get to those numbers and
beyond so make sure you register
at tube 1k channel
all right you waited long enough for
part two let's jump into it
and then i'll catch you afterwards to
recap what we learned
in our last episode we talked about
trend surfing but in this episode i'm
excited to talk about
influence surfing or rather influence
drafting
you know the analogy of surfing is
trends are
like things that are waves on the ocean
and that if you're out there ready to
catch them that you paddle out catch the
wave
ride it while the trend is big and then
once it dies out you paddle back out to
catch another
wave influence surfing trend surfing
but i was inspired because tony areola
on the think media
team actually kind of gave us some
different language
for this strategy of influence surfing
and he calls it
influence drafting like in an indie race
like indy 500
where two cars will draft behind one car
will draft behind another
to really be more efficient and to
really speed up if you will
their results and maybe you remember the
movie days of thunder
right like i grew up on that movie i've
got a couple stepbrothers and my stepdad
they we were into that whole era that
was tom cruise not just days of thunder
but top gun you remember that era
and and it was this movie all about
uh racing right and indie racing
um i actually looked up a couple quotes
from mario andretti a famous race car
driver
to kind of kick us into gear on the
podcast today and one of his quotes was
this
if everything seems under control you're
not going fast enough
or here's another one if you're afraid
of failure you will never succeed you
have to take
chances here's another one from mario
andretti
if you wait all that happens
is that you get older come on it's time
to take action
but i was inspired because as tony's
talking about influence drafting
here's the nascar term and what it means
it's the practice of
two or more cars while racing to run
nose to tail
almost touching the lead car by
displacing the air in front creates a
vacuum between its rear end
and the nose of the following car
actually
pulling the second car along with it
right that's what drafting is well what
is influence
drafting well when a video is breaking
out on youtube in the youtube algorithm
it's pulling views it's getting views
it's pushing views rather
and so your goal is to create a related
video right that comes right up
at the rear end nose to the following
car knows to the following video
that actually gets pulled along by
the influence in that video or the trend
makes sense drafting
and so the difference and why we wanted
to do two episodes with this is trend
surfing in our opinion they kind of are
similar but trend surfing or trend
drafting
is events it's products it's a recipe
it's a way of doing things it's a decor
style
it's a certain trend in a certain season
and definitely check out the last
episode
if you want to go a little bit deeper on
that but in part two we want to talk
about
influence drafting and this is really
about people
influencers people that have influence a
person that is
known when someone is known when maybe
somebody known does something
crazy or does something inspirational
all of a sudden that's pushing views on
youtube
and by using this strategy your goal is
to draft your video behind that
to get some views from the suggested and
recommended
engine on youtube the youtube algorithm
once a video takes off
you can draft with it because you might
not have influence
but this person might have influence
that you can connect to well sean this
sounds
real hypothetical how do you do this
well here's some examples
one of my friends charlie has a channel
named charisma on command
5 million subscribers 10 million views a
month
and he uses influence
surfing or influence drafting basically
in every video
some of his most popular videos this one
has
ellen in the thumbnail ellen degeneres
and it's
three jokes that make people instantly
like you
from ellen degeneres now his channel is
all about charisma his channel is all
about
how to communicate in social situations
maybe you want to
find a partner build a relationship with
uh you know
date somebody you know open up a
conversation to build a friendship so
it's all that kind of
teaching and it's all that kind of
psychology and mindset content
but see some channels they just go
directly at it they just might be like
how to break the ice in a social
conversation right
but ellen's not involved obviously
you start pulling principles from ellen
degeneres someone who's known
someone who's in the thumbnail and three
jokes that she uses that make
people instantly like you and you are
seeing influence drafting in
action ellen's pushing all these views
on youtube as well as just across
media in general so when she shows up in
your thumbnail
related to your niche and your content
it can be very powerful for driving
views for you
and and charisma on command is getting
10 million views a month so this is
working
he's got a video how to be popular as an
introvert lessons from keanel reeves
and he got keanu reeves in the thumbnail
interestingly enough you don't have
charlie in the thumbnail because
ultimately if you are new to the channel
you don't know him
but you know keanu reeves and you're
introduced to his voice and eventually
him on camera
later on in the video as he uses b-roll
and examples from keanu reeves work
but this is influence drafting elon musk
how to achieve 10x more than your peers
so again
you could maybe arguably say i've done
more than my peers
but people may not know you but they
know elon so if there's principles from
his life
of how to achieve 10x more than your
peers you're tapping into a lot of
powerful content
and this is seeing influence surfing or
influenced drafting in action
you know this works on a news channel as
well we talked about bobby eberly who's
a news channel and whatever your
background or your beliefs
some people are conservative some people
are liberal some people are in the media
some people are
conspiracy theory like you could be all
over the board right but
but bobby eberly he's got a conservative
news channel it's not just trends
he also talks about people presidents
you know heads of state what congress is
doing he's really talking about american
politics
so he gets a lot of views and awareness
because he's tapping into trends and
influence greater than his own you know
on think media we did this
years ago when i was just by myself i
was a solo creator
as you may be listening to this right
now and i saw an opportunity
when a creator named casey neistat
neistat started a daily vlog
he kind of reinvented the industry
because he was bringing a much higher
camera quality
much better audio quality and really
almost like
a solo person filmmaking channel as
opposed to just a
kind of a low quality haphazard vlogger
and he kind of reintroduced he just he
made waves in the whole thing and he was
experiencing massive growth
well i was watching his vlogs pretty
much daily
and one night i was laying next to my
wife in bed
uh and i was watching casey neistat on
my phone i don't know if that's the
healthiest thing for your marriage i
maybe should have been paying attention
to her but i was paying
attention to casey uh we could talk
about that with our counselor but
anyways
we i'm watching casey and i realized for
the first time of course he was getting
all these inquiries
about what camera gear do you use bro
your quality is different than
everybody's
and he did an episode finally where he
explained it
but he actually only he very casually
was like this is the camera and he
didn't say the lens
he's like this little tripod thing he
didn't say the model he said i got a
shotgun mic he didn't talk about it
so i was like pixel peeping zooming into
every frame
to figure out wait a minute this is an
opportunity i could actually break down
a detailed gear list of casey neistat's
camera gear
no doubt about it a lot of people a lot
of people knew casey they didn't know
sean cannell or think media yet
right and we've grown over the years but
i'm a smaller creator at the time like
you may be right now
so i use influence surfing influence
drafting
to make this video this video ends up
with a couple hundred it's on its way to
400 000 views
and really for the niche i'm in helping
people with cameras helping people with
gear
explaining things tapping into
casey's influence we did an episode
recently on video podcasting and we
called it the joe rogan video podcast
formula
we just talked about why it's good to do
a video podcast because you can tap into
youtube
you can cut clips out of those episodes
and not
just be on audio platforms and we just
explained some things that joe rogan
does
in a very honoring way to his work and
in in a very
detailed way to serve people that are
maybe thinking about starting a video
podcast
and would like to know some of the
technical deal details behind the scenes
a lot more people know joe rogan
than sean cannell and this is the power
right of tapping into
influence drafting faceless channels
across youtube are earning hundreds of
thousands of dollars a month
by making whole channels based off
celebrities athletes
movies actors tapping into their
influence emily baker a friend of mine
is
a former trial attorney still a lawyer
that now is a full-time influencer and
youtube creator
and she breaks down the legal cases
between big youtubers and celebrities
her expertise of literally opening up
the public documents
of somebody suing somebody else and
reading through it line by line and
pointing things out
have amassed a massive community of what
they call themselves
law nerds that want to hear her insights
and point of view
on all of these huge profile cases
with all this legal detail that just
comes from her background
as a lawyer and as an attorney
entertainment channels think about this
if you've ever watched
what are the best new releases on
netflix this month i watch these all the
time
uh ending of fill-in-the-blank movie
explained as soon as i finish the movie
i go to youtube
so these channels are tapping into the
influence of a movie they're tapping
into the influence of netflix
they're tapping into movie reviews even
in movie reactions
they didn't make the movie they are
drafting
right there's that lead car pushing the
views
they get right behind it with some
content and they're being pulled
along by the influence of these other
projects
now you might ask sean well how do you
do this though like wait a minute how
can
charisma on command like put ellen
in their thumbnail how can these movie
review channels
put clips of these movies in their
actual video
how do you actually talk about athletes
and celebrities
and without going too far in into it the
the key here
it's called fair use what is fair use
it's a u.s copyright law
and here's what it is it's the doctrine
that the doctrine that
brief experts brief excerpts
of copyright material may under certain
circumstances
be quoted verbatim for purposes such as
criticism
right like reacting criticizing giving
your point of view to it
news reporting hence how news channels
can use clips from movies and
clips from the internet and clips from
all over because they're
reporting on it teaching teaching about
it
so if you're teaching three jokes that
make people instantly like you lessons
from ellen
you're not just stealing her whole
episode downloading it and re-uploading
it that's a copyright violation
you're using brief excerpts to teach
and research many documentaries people
breaking things down
without the need this is fair use of
getting permission or
payment to the copyright holder so you
don't need the copyright holders
permission or payment now
you might have a million questions about
that and this podcast is not the time
for that
like this is an ongoing debate there's
ongoing things in court here's what you
need to know
the court rulings have been very
favorable towards creators
to give us the ability to use fair use
in our youtube content and our content
across the internet
but what i can't promise you is that
videos won't get flagged
on charisma on command a lot of times
their videos don't have any drama they
don't get flagged
but whenever they talk about the ufc for
example to talk about
conor mcgregor or big fights or big
profile fights
almost instantly those videos get
flagged now check it out
you can dispute those claims and say no
that's it's fair use
um i you know this is used properly and
so
charisma on command disputes those it
oftentimes takes weeks or even months
they win eventually but a lot of times
they lose out on the monetization
while the video is kind of in purgatory
it's just in that middle world of of
waiting until there's clarity on
that particular video but here's the
thing if you're going to use this
strategy you can't be afraid of that
it's you need to be wise do your
research you can look up fair use and
there's good youtube videos on it and
it's an evolving thing
and it's just it's part more than part
it is the essence
of influence drafting that you have to
be comfortable with to realize it's a
skill set you got to develop
and you might say i don't even want to
deal with it i just want to always be on
camera i just want to do my own thing
remember
this is just one tool
in your tool belt we got so many tools
for you that's the point of this podcast
that's the point of our upcoming
challenge that's the point of our
annual event coming up soon growth video
live is to give you the tools
to pick the tools you want to use
different people use different tools
to even get to the same end destination
but fair use is the way these channels
are doing it
and they're continuing to use nuanced
strategies around that
so that they can ultimately draft off
the
influence of celebrities athletes
movies trending headlines news
political events you know global events
all kinds of different things
using footage in brief excerpts
commentary
combining it all together to make videos
that make a massive impact so a couple
here's a couple formulas as we lay on
the plane
think about maybe even making a video
like this sean how would this apply to
my niche
i'm not really connecting the dots yet i
see the power of it but i'm not sure
imagine just making a video like this
three lessons i learned
from a famous person in your niche or
your niche
like coming up soon i'm excited because
i've learned a bunch of lessons
from dave ramsey about youtube maybe
you've heard of dave ramsey's a personal
finance guy
how to get out of debt things like that
but so see i'm
we teach youtube right we're helping you
with youtube we're helping you win on
youtube
so i'm tying in known person
to lessons i've learned about youtube
because he's got 2 million subscribers
and multiple other channels that have
hundreds of thousands
and he's doing some cool strategies so
if you're not subscribed to the think
media podcast definitely subscribe
whether on the channel spotify apple
because that's coming up soon
but that is an example right of
influence drafting well listen
also adding value doing your research
adding real value real insights
nobody really talks about dave ramsey
that way they they think about there's
other perspectives on
i i'm just looking at through the lens
of three lessons i've learned about
youtube from famous person
in your niche or just in general they
don't actually have to be a famous
person in your niche
they just are a known person and you're
extrapolating insights
from their life their business their
approach
here's another one reacting to somebody
reacting to something
someone influential did so
if you have the courage again you might
agree with the person you might disagree
you may just observe you may use it as a
a
point of jumping off uh to lead to
something you teach or your book or your
channel
but you could be if you had a cooking
channel you could be trying
gordon ramsay's recipe you know you
could go polarizing and you could go
you know gordon ramsay is a horrible
cook like
it's up to you but like you're reacting
you're saying he did it this way
i'm gonna do it this way she did it this
way and here's another one
how to edit like famous youtubers
like ex-famous youtuber how to edit like
mr beast if you had an editing channel
you know today at the very time we're
recording this podcast
nolan mo on the think media team
released a video of 10
edits that famous youtubers use and he
talked about yes theory and talked about
mr beast he talked about peter mckinnon
those people are in the thumbnails their
footage is in the video it's a great
example of
fair use and definitely check out our
think media channel where you can see
more about that but i'm not saying that
is your title
we help you with editing on our channel
think media so you can tie in
editing tips as opposed to this is a
adobe premiere tutorial welcome
we have that too this is just a tool
that you can use in your tool belt that
can really help you draft
behind someone that's really pushing
views pulling your video
along with their influence so ask
yourself
how to do x like a famous person
on youtube or in hollywood that's
related to what you do
on your channel my friend i really
believe that as you tap into
influence surfing aka influence
drafting you'll be able to make a
massive impact and potentially have a
breakout video
that grows your channel grows your
revenue and ultimately grows your
youtube
business so try this one out and let us
know how the results go
all right well after those two episodes
all about trend surfing i hope you have
a
list of video ideas what's the next
video that you need to create
how are you going to incorporate trend
surfing and influence
drafting on your next video now
warning warning warning if you are like
me
you've probably made an entire list of
videos and you're contemplating which
one to do next maybe you're going to do
some more research
but really what you're doing is
procrastinating let me know if that
is something you do that's what i do
when i get into
the zone of research on youtube here's
what i need you to do
i need you to just press record this is
your time
to find the trends and start surfing
them this is the time
to figure out how you can do something
in your niche that's different than
other people
are doing i know you haven't in you and
i want to just encourage you
to not wait on this this is your
opportunity
to build influence to build authority
and
to get views and subscribers on youtube
so
your chance right now or not chance but
what you need to do next
is make the video and if you're still
kind of stuck
you want to figure out what to do next
then you should make sure that you sign
up for our
five day challenge it's right around the
corner and i
recommend that all people who are
content creators
take one of our free challenges this is
the next one that we have
of brand new content helping you get to
your first 1000 subscribers
and first 1 000 on youtube
if you've made those milestones already
don't worry this challenge is for you as
well because we're helping you go
beyond that during this challenge so
five days coming right up make sure you
register at
tube1kchallenge.com and if you
are a part of the think community and
you've left
a review over on itunes i keep saying
itunes i don't even know if it's itunes
is it itunes or podcast let me know in
the comments if you're watching on
youtube
where you're leaving these you're
leaving rates and reviews over on
apple and when you do that i'm able to
actually read them
here on the podcast and today's comes
from lynn
love now lynn love says the think media
team is amazing and can i just shout out
to the think media team
you see heather and sean here on camera
but there is an entire
team of amazing people behind us
making this podcast happen so i want to
shout out to our team
everyone over at think media we are you
know
20 10 20 people deep really making this
whole
uh company happens so shout out to the
team thank you
lynn love she says i've been following
think media since i heard about them
last year
boy am i glad i did i'm glad you did too
lynn
now if i can just find the time to put
everything they have taught me to use
by trying to but trying to juggle work
school starting my own
profit get my qualifications for my
non-profit and figure out how to use my
youtube to promote my nonprofit is a lot
of work
i highly suggest if you want to start
youtube
follow them they know what they are
doing well lynn i just want to encourage
you and say
you've got a lot on your plate girl and
i know that it can be hard
but i remember myself five years ago
10 years ago listening to my mentors
being in such a place where i wasn't
even able to be creating content but i
knew i needed to
and when i made that first step when i
just decided that
i will do this until i figure it out
when i figured out if i can just keep it
simple right if i can just make videos
that are simple
that it would all work out and so lynn i
want to encourage you that while you're
doing all that
just start getting a video out once a
week and lynn
what video are you gonna make that is
all about trend surfing and
influence surfing well thank you so much
for listening to today's episode
we love hearing from our think community
in the youtube comments and over
on apple we are so grateful for your
time
we know that you're probably listening
to this while you're driving in your car
or walking your dog
or doing your dishes or doing your
makeup like i do in the morning
and i just want to thank you for
bringing us into your homes for bringing
us into your ears and for being a part
of this
movement of creators who are making an
impact
in the world thanks for listening and
we'll catch you in the next episode
not growing on youtube learn the newest
strategies for getting views and the
best proven ways to make money
at grow with video live a two-day
virtual conference
and you can get your tickets today at
girlwithvideolive.com
you